JP in New York JP not really adding up
again I'm on the app watching our other
father and all I'm looking at in Gary
and his belly how is he on that pellet
even using it you know I gotta tell you
[Laughter]
you know I had a buddy over my house on
Friday night and he said hey you do that
exercise bike the peloton what's that
like and I'm telling him how great it is
and he goes he knows Gary goes what's we
Gary he goes hey he's got one of those
in East Patty's [ __ ] what's going on I
mean you work out hard I've seen you
even run you run like a maniac why are
you eating so much food that like it's
impossible to lose weight yeah you know
what I definitely either what are you
eating
do you eat all the fish in the ocean I
mean do you have a normal portion yeah I
get it
I'm the first one to tell me what you
eat when you wake up cuz I mean you the
peloton so this morning I had I have
eggs scrambled eggs good with avocado
that's it slice no bread no bread all
right that so that's a good start
yeah but something happened I don't I'm
ready maybe at lunch I goes between
either so you don't eat til lunch I'll
have a couple of pieces of plantains or
something like that
munchkins I have weren't you eating
caramel popcorn out of a can with a
spoon it was last week I'm not sitting
here and saying yo if I can find
chocolate on my office I'll eat
chocolate right other words the eggs in
avocado a great start to the day good
start but then you start snacking yeah
it's a better story than if it were say
a bacon egg and cheese sandwich
did we doughnuts this morning I had one
of the Munchkins oh my god no I like my
duck well oh my god is right I mean the
one day I mean you're heavy guy form and
exercise you do we kept this guy from
buying an exercise bike